[Musique]
abbas n c'est une jeune entreprise créée
en 2015 dont le métier est de déployer
des capteurs dans les espaces de nature
en ville les espaces publics est ensuite
utilisé les données issues de ces
capteurs à travers différents usages que
ce soit des six nations du jardinier
pour faire en sorte qu'on n'est plus
d'efficience dans la gestion de la
nature en ville ou pour l'utilisateur
final de ces espaces dans lesquels vous
cherche à créer de nouveaux usages de
prise de conscience de connaissance des
espaces de nature en ville et surtout
des êtres vivants qu'il est qui les
habitent ces espaces de nature en ville
c'est l'objectif
notre client ici et l'aménageur paris
saclay avec qui on a tissé une relation
petit à petit de confiance et à qui on a
pu proposer une prestation innovante qui
est toujours appuyé sur des capteurs
déployés dans l'environnement mais qui
ont une autre finalité que celle de
l'économie d'eau qui est davantage celle
du porter à connaissance de la
biodiversité et des animaux qui habitent
les espaces naturels qui nous entoure
donc la première étape était
l'acquisition de contenus médias photos
et vidéos dans les espaces naturels donc
principalement les espaces boisés autour
de polytechnique la zac du moulin à la
recherche de d'animaux qui se déplace
plutôt la nuit donc qui sont très
difficiles à observer comme par exemple
des renards des lapins des hérissons
l'objectif était d'acquérir ces médias
pour les rediffuser ensuite aux usagers
des espaces de nature et donc on a
choisi une portion de trajet
régulièrement empruntée par une partie
des habitants du plateau qui se situe
entre la gare rer et le haut du plateau
avec l'école polytech sur ce trajet nous
avons disposé des balises qui sont
accessibles depuis une application
smartphone et qui permettent de
récupérer en passant à côté de la balise
les médias que nous avons récemment
acquis dans les bois alentour ces
contenus seront renouvelés chaque jour
et pour chacune des balises ce qui
permet d'avoir une expérience renouvelée
à chaque passage
je vous invite tous acteurs du plateau
de saclay à venir découvrir le parcours
de diversité que nous avons mis en place
sur le plateau
[Musique]